le chum est enfin achevé le dernier
pavillon construit sur le site de
l'ancien hôpital saint luc qui a été
démolie en avril 2018 est maintenant
prêt à accueillir ses premiers patients
mais après des années de débats de
report et aussi de controverse sur
l'emplacement du futur méga hôpital
entre autres sur le terrain de la gare
de triage d'outremont et bien le projet
est finalement lancé
c'est le premier ministre jean charest
accompagné des ministres yves bolduc et
monique gagnon tremblay qui a donné la
première pelletée de terre au projet le
25 mars 2010
une construction évaluée à cette époque
à près d'un demi milliard de dollars
le méga hôpital est enfin terminé et
aura coûté finalement 3 milliards 600
millions de dollars
cette fois plus on rentre dans le
nouveau maintenant voici à quoi
ressemble le nouveau pavillon qui
accueille un centre ambulatoire est
aussi le centre de cancérologie intégrer
on a intégré tous les besoins des
patients avec cancer sur place y compris
s'il ya des urgences
ce qui frappe le plus en circulant dans
les nouveaux locaux et bien c'est
l'espace la lumière et surtout des vues
magnifiques sur la ville le centre
hospitalier de l'université de montréal
et le plus grand au québec est parmi
l'un des plus importants au canada qui
si c'est toute une équipe qui s'occupe
de vos ce qu'on appelle une famille et
est en fait le patient se sent comme au
sein d'une famille et non pas dans un
hôpital froid le nouveau pavillon
accueille également une bibliothèque qui
sera éventuellement ouverte au public
le chum c'est aussi un centre de
recherche et 17 mille employés
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal